[Musique]
l'aigu font partie intégrante du paysage
de seattle économie fleurissante clore
sa ville au deuxième rang en termes de
croissance aux états unis
seattle héberge plusieurs
multinationales comme boeing et
microsoft mais à lui seul le géant du
commerce en ligne amazon emploie près de
quarante mille personnes
la ligue nationale de hockey voilà un
terreau fertile pour son expansion
john barry convaincu du potentiel de ces
régions l'ingénieur en informatique fait
la promotion de la candidature de
seattle et il n'est pas seul à attendre
la lnh cet homme a déjà fait un dépôt
pour des pires saisons
d'ailleurs 33 mille billets ont été
réservés les 10 mai le premier en 12
minutes à peine
[Musique]
en comparaison à las vegas en 2016 9000
billets avaient trouvé preneurs en un
mois pour l'instant l'agglomération de
trois millions et demi d'habitants ne
compte que deux équipes de hockey junior
majeur nous sommes la dernière grande
ville des etats-unis à se tourner vers
leurs acquis explique-t-il en fait il
n'y a aucune patinoire assiette aux
mêmes et à peine une demi douzaine dans
la région
j'ai mis ostroff un ancien joueur de la
lnh en gère 2 s'il n'y a pas plus
d'arena explique-t-il c'est en partie à
cause du prix et de la rareté des
terrains dans la région
la voie pour la lnh s'est ouverte en
décembre quand la ville a conclu une
entente de principe avec le groupe oc
view pour rénover le client win a
construit pour l'expo de seattle en 1962
il sera remise à neuf au coût de 600
millions dollars américains
je crois que ça va être privé la ville
demeure propriétaire est lourd à l'aréna
au groupe o view pendant 39 ans
tout le contraire de québec où le centre
vidéotron a été payée entièrement par la
ville et la province
un modèle mais une fois écartées à
seattle
même si la ville contribuera à sa façon
ce spécialiste précise que les taxes
générées par les activités de l'aréna
seront réinvestis dans sa gestion et son
entretien le groupe ont vu ne
s'intéresse pas qu'au rock et heavy rain
et de basketball de la nba ocarina les
supersonics ont quitté seattle en 2008
pour s'établir à oklahoma city
et depuis seul stand de seattle une
équipe professionnelle féminine dispute
ses matches ici ça pourrait changer
d'ici quelques années
je crois que oui parce que
à moyen terme ça voudrait dire beaucoup
plus de compétition pour les mariners au
baseball les seahawks au football et
laissant deux jokers pour l'instant
l'argent des partis sang coule à flots
mais les dangers d'un ralentissement
économique et d'une saturation du marché
existe mais chaque chose en son temps
les gouverneurs de la lnh doivent
d'abord accepter la candidature de la
ville ce qui pourrait être fait dès le
mois de juin
et si antoine et radio-canada seattle
[Musique]